Let's look at another simplification process involving negative exponents. I'm
going to show you two ways of doing this problem, and then you can pick which
one you prefer. We learned before that a base with a negative exponent can be
moved to the denominator. So we'll have 1 divided by 2 cubed times 2 squared, or
1 divided by 2 to the 5th. If this gives you some trouble, try applying your
exponent rules directly. We know when we divide bases, we subtract the
exponents. So we have 2 to the negative 2 minus 3, negative 2 minus 3 equals
negative 5. And finally we have a base with a negative exponent, so we move the
base to the denominator with a positive exponent. Leaving us with 1 divided by 2
to the 5th. And that's exactly the same as we got before.